- This is torture to my tongue right now.
(laughs)
- My tongue's like, what do you want?
Do you want to be clean
or do you want to be a mess?
(upbeat music)
- I have coffee breath a lot.
- Well, we both wear retainers.
(upbeat music)
- You can like, see the smell
coming out of this thing right now.
- It's so garlicky.
- So he has to kiss me,
then blow in my face? Okay.
- This is actually how we always do kiss.
- Ugh!
(laughs)
- It's like somebody vomited,
like, a pizza.
(upbeat music)
- The bad smell, from what I've been told,
comes from the back of the tongue.
(brushing sounds)
- And then move slowly...
- I am 27 years old! I
can brush my own teeth.
- He's a pretty good flosser.
- You flossed all your teeth?
- I flossed the important ones.
(smack)
- That's great.
- Ew.
(exhales)
- Yeah, no. Not too bad.
- That's awesome.
- We did it!
- That's super refreshing.
(upbeat music)
- Curiously strong mints.
- Ugh, just like eating chalk.
- It's like, curiously weak, actually.
- Oh.
- The kiss was like, it like
neutralized all the food.
- Ugh.
- You can smell the altoid
but it smells like you ate altoids
on top of garlic bread and chips.
(upbeat music)
- Binaca!
- Yeah, this is like a thing
that happens in movies.
- Hey, are you gonna go see Sally later?
- You know it, Bro Bro.
(spray spray)
(laughter)
(gags)
- In your mouth.
- This was like, a subtle
hint of mint flavor
with overwhelming garlic butter.
- Pretty good.
- What!
- That was really good.
- Ugh, how about I just
put this up my nose.
(snorts)
(upbeat music)
- This tiny strip can't do anything.
- It's burning my tongue.
- Oh, got stuck on the roof of my mouth.
- Actually...
- There you go.
- That was pretty good.
- That works.
- So you're telling me that one of these
was better than me brushing
my teeth thoroughly,
brushing my tongue thoroughly,
and then flossing.
- It really was able to like, penetrate...
(laughs)
- The pungent smell of the other...
things that you've eaten.
(upbeat music)
- You're running out of your house,
you just swig some listerine,
spit it, and then you're good to go.
(gargling)
- Is it hurting?
- Umh.
(snickers)
- So I think what it is is like,
it's back in your throat.
- Ew.
- That one was good.
Or I'm just really
getting used to the smell.
(upbeat music)
If you're gonna kiss somebody
after you've eaten garlic,
you should wait about like, six months.
- Brush your teeth.
- They know that they're
supposed to brush their teeth.
(laughs)
- If you got to pick
one, what would you say?
- I can't.
- Our breath is, here and
there, up and down, right?
- Yeah.
- So I think we've gotten used to it.
So I don't think we need to
go anywhere else from there.
- Good job.
- Thanks.
(high five slap)
- If I can only have one of those products
which one would you choose?
- I would choose to
walk down the street...
- No, that's not an
option, you cannot do that.
- And get in my car and drive away.
- You can't, if I give you options
you can't create another option.
- Well why not?
- That's not how it works.
- Oh well, we're gonna change the rules.
(scoffs)